Hank the tiny chickens are inside my
head and they are breeding the problem
is that as the tiny chickens breed they
can't get out so they're just filling up
my head with pain but Hank I do want to
talk to you today about something I've
been thinking about a lot going with
your gut which I am opposed to okay so
the other day I was changing Henry's
diaper and I don't know if you know this
about babies but when you're changing
their diapers sometimes they will
urinate or defecate because they think
it's funny and I'm just getting the new
diaper on when this fountain of pee just
erupts and in that moment I thought to
myself what am I going to do about this
at which point a dumb little voice
inside of me said go with your gut
you have good parental instincts and
what my gut told me to do was to cut my
hands where the fountain of pee was
landing and just gather the urine in my
cupped hands which I did and it worked
great and then I'm standing there with
two handfuls of urine and Hank as you
know the human hand is not really meant
to be a waterproof cup so I'm kind of
walking it around and it's dribbling all
over my feet and then I started
screaming Sara Sara there's pee all in
my hands and she says we'll just drop it
at which point I basically dropped poor
Henry's pee on poor Henry's peepee
stupid gut whereas if I'd used my nerd
brain I would have grabbed the diaper I
was about to use put it over the
fountain and solve the problem right
then the other reason I don't go with my
gut is that when my gut isn't giving me
bad advice it only tells me one thing
eat by the way Hank just for future
reference I'm counting on you and the
nerdfighters to let me know when I get
fat and you failed on that front
I mean sure they were hints a few days
ago a nerdfighter said that I looked
like the lead singer of the Barenaked
Ladies
really also there was a hilarious recent
youtube comment I won't share the
username but in a thread about whether
you or I was hot or someone said John is
like your smart uncle and Hank is like
your hot cousin you're a hot cousin
by the way nerdfighters just a quick
piece of advice your relationship with
your smart uncle and your hot cousin
should be the same platonic but anyway
Hank I am NOT a subtle person when I'm
fat you need to tell me John you're fat
instead I had to go to the doctor a
month ago and step on the scale and find
that for the first time since I was like
eight there is a new first number in my
weight so in addition to having tiny
chicken disease for the last two weeks
I've been on a cleanse yes I follow
amanda bynes on twitter i read wyneth
Paltrow's newsletter and I'm on a
cleanse so far I've lost 12 pounds can
you tell can you see it in the face at
all and I could lose another two pounds
just by getting a haircut anyway the
reason I'm losing weight is because I am
not listening to my gut because my gut
right now is like feed me I will eat
this feed me that that's fine it looks
like it has some carbs in it no no no
but my brain knows that I can't eat this
my little pony even though it would be
delicious not only because it would be
caloric but also because it's the only
my little pony in the world with a black
Santa and a license plate from gutshot
Tennessee for my little pony didn't make
any jokes about Looking for Alaska so
Hank the world can go on celebrating
emotionalism and gut instincts but I'm
gonna be a nerdfighter by getting fit
and avoiding pee with my brain Hank I'll
see you on Monday